[Upbeat bass music]
- Anybody in here into fashion?
- [Scottie Barnes:] I'd say I'm into it a lil' bit.
- [Tyrese Haliburton:] Gettin' there.
- [Dwyane Wade:] You're gettin' there?
- [Obi Toppin:] I'm trying to get in there.
- [Napheesa Collier:] I mean—
- Trying to get in there?
- I'm trying to.
- What does the future look like in fashion?
- Uh—
- Scottie, you raised your hand first.
- Yeah.
- So what is fashion to you?
- I don't know.
To me, it's just really things that really just catch my eye.
I feel like when I look at something and I feel
like I can see myself in it,
I would go out my way to try to
get it and put it on
and see how I can put it on the right way.
You know, my way.
- Does price matter?
- Nah, not at this point, you know?
- [All laughing]
- Got a lil' bit of money,
so, you know.
- Fashion to me is being able to put things together—
- Yeah.
- No matter what the name is on the tag.
- No matter what the price is.
So, Tyrese, last year you were LeagueFits' MVP.
- Rookie of the Year, Rookie of the Year.
- Oh, Rookie of the Year. OK.
- Sheesh!
- MVP, we'll get there. Just tryna get there.
- So League—so last year, you was
LeagueFits' Rookie of the Year.
- Mmhmm.
- So how do you feel every time
you walk into the arena that
the outfit that you put on would be broadcasted
and talked about all over social media?
- I feel like it's a little bit of an expectation now.
- Yes.
- You feel like you gotta put it on.
- Yeah, a lil' bit.
- You got to.
- I'm just trying to, you know, express myself
through fashion with, like you said,
many different options
and, you know, just put anything on,
no matter the price.
But that be the hardest part now is, like,
I'm trying to tap into a different sense of style.
- [Wade:] Yeah.
- And, like, I'm not paying that for a jacket.
- [All laughing]
- You know what I'm saying?
- [Toppin:] No way.
- Like, it's just not gonna happen.
- It's a competition in dressing,
just like it's a competition on the court.
When you walk through that tunnel,
I think everybody wanna look the best.
You know, they wanna have the best fit
on, the best shoes on.
You know, everybody wanna get praised.
Everybody wanna feel good about their outfit.
Especially after you spent all that money on it,
you want somebody to say you look kinda dope.
- Do you guys ever worry about this?
Cuz I feel like we do. Like, it's an awesome fit,
but then the picture's bad.
- Ohh!
- [Collier:] Like, so do you go look at the pictures?
- [All agreeing]
- Yeah. And it's like, you can't post it
cuz it doesn't look the way it looks in person.
- Mmhmm.
- The picture's bad.
- I ain't gonna lie. Me, when I walk in there,
I'mma do my pose.
- [Wade laughing]
- I'mma, I'mma do the pose I want.
- [Collier:] You're gonna ask to see the picture, aren't you?
- [Wade:] Whatcha gonna do?
- If it's a bad walk, you gonna rewalk?
You goin' back up and go back?
- [Barnes:] Nah, nah, nah, nah, nah.
- [Haliburton:] I've done that before.
- You never rewalked?
- [Haliburton:] I've done that before
- You rewalk?!
- You've re—wait, wait, wait.
- [Toppin:] I mean, like, 10 times in a row.
- Nah, no way!
- I used to back and forth, back and forth.
- Not 10!
- [Haliburton:] I've rewalked.
- I need the right steps. You need the right head—
- [Haliburton:] I've rewalked for sure.
- Y'all rewalk into the arena?!
- [Haliburton:] But let me—but no, not in the arena but like to the,
to the, to the bus.
- [Barnes:] I'm saying, at home games
I might be—
- To the bus on the,
on the road, or if—
- Oh, OK, so you come out the hotel.
- [Barnes:] On the road?
- [Topping:] Nah, this is only at home.
This is only at home.
- [Barnes:] Yeah, that's what I'm sayin'.
- This is not at at an away.
- Home, I might do it.
- [Toppin:] You gonna look crazy you
do anything like that.
- At home, I might do the rewalk. Be like, "All right."
- This is a different generation, but I don't—
- [All laughing]
- If I walk in and you, and you like, "I didn't get it," I'm like—
- [Toppin:] You know when it's a bad picture.
- "I'll go back. I'll go back.
You want me to go back?" And I'll turn back around.
- [Laughing]
- Yeah. You know when it's a good picture
- How do you know it's a good picture
if you don't see it?
You just feel it?
- I feel like you feel it.
Like, you know how you was looking. You know
if you had a weird face, like, walking—
- Facts.
- Walking or not. You're like, "Ah, nah, I gotta—"
- [Laughing]
- The worst part, when you go,
when you put a fit on and you walk
in and there's no camera.
- [Laughing]
- You be like—
- Oh, my goodness.
- "I just wasted this whole outfit."
- "I just wasted this fit."
- I ain't gonna lie, I'mma still get a picture.
- And you can't wear it again cuz your teammates—
- I'mma get it on my phone or something.
- Jason Richardson, Jason Richardson posted
this year about that.
He started, like, taking,
like, "Y'all gonna get these photos."
- Yeah.
- "Y'all gonna get these fits."
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- It's a fact
- Also where they're positioned. I know if you're too low. Like,
I don't want it right there.
- Yes!
- Mmm.
- I need you to stand up and then I'll come.
- Stand up a lil'.
- Yeah.
- Where's the next 25 years of fashion going?
Are we controlling our own clothes?
Are we creating our own brands?
Or are we still buying
from all the top design houses in the world?
- I feel like we definitely have the platform.
We just have to find someone who, like,
if it's their interest, it'll happen,
because people are gonna see.
Like, you'll be able to push it out there in the media.
- [Wade:] Yeah.
- So, like, if you wanted to create a fashion line
when you were in the league,
like, people were gonna buy that.
- I see athletes taking over, taking on their own brands.
The moment I thought to make my own brand was I felt
like I was at the heights of being Swaggy P, you know?
I'd been wearing so many other brands.
It was time for me to do my own thing.
Course, Melo, Melo Ball.
He's somebody that's gonna push the, push the league forward.
You gonna have to buy some Melos from Melo and
some Jas from Ja.
And that's dope cuz, you know,
that's them.
I think that's the way it should be.
- What does the future look like?
Like, what would you wanna see?
- Scottie, what you gonna have on?
- [Laughing]
- When I was young, we wore big white tees,
about 4X, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we can't go back there.
- [All agreeing]
- OK, so we're not going—
- [Collier:] Like, the 2000s are coming back,
like, in the fashion trends right now.
- But everything in fashion comes back, right?
- [Collier:] Yeah.
- [Haliburton:] I do like some things baggy—
- [Barnes:] Yeah.
- [Haliburton:] But, like, your draft suit—
- [Toppin:] The baggy shirts, baggy shirts are good. I like baggy shirts.
- [Collier:] I like the mixture when, like, some—like
the under is tighter than the over.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [All agreeing]
- [Collier:] Like, everything baggy is not good.
- [Haliburton:] Nah, nah. Like, y'all's draft suits—
- [Toppin:] Those draft suits.
- What's up with our draft suits?
- [Laughing]
- [Collier:] The flared pants were the worst.
- Yeah, like, those can't come back.
Please don't come back
- The pants were the worst.
- We can't do that, please!
- [Wade:] You said "please."
- [All laughing]
- In 25 years, um, man, I just wanna be
able to see really.
[Laughing]
It's gonna be, it's gonna be different
I don't know what to expect now,
so. People wearin' tights [sighing]. Dresses.
I think they gonna do whatever they want, man,
and that's a good thing,
cuz they want you to do it now. Back then,
they didn't want you to express yourself like that.
So now they get to express they self
in a way that they want, and it's not frowned upon.
They get to enjoy fashion, get to enjoy being who they are.
- We're able to express ourselves through fashion.
Someone may never get an opportunity to talk
to either one of us or have a conversation,
but they can see what you're wearing and be like—
they can get an idea of your personality.
- Yeah.
- Or how you feel.
So, Tyrese, you made a statement
on draft night when you got drafted.
- Yeah, I knew I wanted to do, you know
something. And we had such a long predraft,
and all during that predraft was,
you know, the George Floyd stuff and
all these different things and
these different movements.
So, I knew that I wanted to represent my city on one side,
but Black Lives Matter on the other.
Like, they was talking about doing just,
like, a black suit or like—I was like, "No, I need to go
to somebody who is gonna do something different."
- [Wade:] Yeah.
- And I always knew
that I wanted to do a pattern of some sort.
And then just putting that on the inside,
I think, tied it all together.
But we talked about expressing ourselves in
in fashion in so many different ways.
Like, I wear so many different vintage T-shirts
that got like, you know, wrestling or something on it
cuz that's what I like.
You know what I mean?
- [Wade:] Yeah.
- I grew up a wrestling fan and, like, that,
like, people will know
that automatically just by seeing what I wear.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- So, just being able to show yourself in your clothes,
I think, is important.
- So the confidence, just to go back to that, the confidence.
The past, a lot—as athletes, you know,
wasn't a lot of social activism that was public.
And now today it's more social activism going on.
So as a young player coming in,
what gave you the confidence to make
that stand or use your clothes as your voice?
- Oh, just being—that's just who I am,
you know? I think that's a testament to how I've been raised
and, you know, just standing up for what I believe in.
And, you know, I think, you know,
the guys like you, guys like Bron, who have, you know,
kinda laid that groundwork for us to,
as athletes, to speak our mind and, you know,
we talk about being more than an athlete and
doing all these different things.
- Yeah.
- You know, I think that that helps us
as younger guys come into the league right away
and not be afraid to use our voice and be who we are.
[Upbeat guitar music]
- This generation is ready for whatever.
I think they got the best opportunity, really,
cuz they got the social media.
They got the NFTs. They just, they got it all.
Fashion and the NFTs, I think, it's a place where
you can be creative and, you know,
really make what you really want.
You know, I think it give, it give
the fans a chance to get something personal
from you, you know? Your personal shoe
or your personal NFT, T-shirt or whatever you make.
And that's just for them.
So, I think that's why it's boomin' right now.
The next 25, I think it's in good hands.
From watching these playoffs,
I think they been setting the tone.